bruno mouron et photographe il sillonne
la planète pour les plus grands
magazines
ce jour là il est dans les locaux de
paris match en plein bouclage dans le
prochain numéro
il y aura sept photos qu'il a prises aux
états unis mais une photo unique un
scoop qu'il va ensuite pouvoir revendre
aux magazines du monde entier
qu'est ce que c'est bon 6 heures du
matin ce immédiate sans hasard alors
c'est qui cet homme qui rend dans la
voiture là c'est richard fields deal au
gorille voilà l'histoire wall street
l'homme le plus détesté des états unis
richard fields
pendant des années il a été un des
patrons les plus respectés de la finance
internationale
il a passé 14 ans à la tête de la
quatrième banque d'affaires aux états
unis
la banque lehman brothers une
institution qui contre toute attente
avait failli
les images de ces salariés vit dans
l'urgence leur bureau un soir du mois de
septembre ont fait le tour du monde pour
avoir investi massivement dans les
placements immobiliers à risque les
fameux subprime
leur patron a conduit l'établissement à
la banqueroute un naufrage qui a
entraîné dans son sillage une crise
financière mondiale sans précédent
richard füle n'est pas le seul dirigeant
mis en cause dans la crise d'autres
grands noms de wall street qui comme les
gagner des dizaines de millions de
dollars par an ont aussi joué avec le
feu c'est le cas par exemple d'alan
fichman le patron des caisses d'épargné
américaines ou de martin sullivan le
patron d'alger le premier assureur
mondial depuis la crise ces patrons se
cache alors que beaucoup voudraient leur
demander des comptes et savoir ce qu'il
devienne pour réaliser son cliché qui
vaut de l'or
bruno mouron à traquer le pdg durant de
longues semaines je pensais jamais ça
allait durer tout ce temps là c'est set
je pensais que bon tout bêtement son
domicile et on allait le voir partir au
bureau lé déjeuner de midi allait faire
du tennis allait faire du squash
enfin on allait faire la totale jamais
pensé qu'on aurait eu 80 mal pour faire
une photo
bon après on a vite compris on a vite
déchanté alors comment le photographe at
il réussi à retrouver la trace de
richard fuld retour sur trois semaines
dans quête à la poursuite de l'homme le
plus haï des états unis new york
au petit matin du mois d'octobre bruno
mouron est aux états unis depuis moins
de 24 heures
c'est aujourd'hui que la traque commence
[Applaudissements]
direction le siège de lehman brothers
l'entrée principale et une autre entrée
qui se trouve un peu derrière qui est
sur la 6e avenue ses débuts les bureaux
de lehman brothers il dit serait encore
il travaillait encore il est 18h45 les
gens vont arriver au bureau donc on va
essayer de voir si la cua c'est vraiment
à la recherche de mr fuld
la banque d'affaires se situe en plein
coeur de manhattan dans le prestigieux
immeuble du rockefeller center
mais il ya un problème le bâtiment
comporte de multiples accès pour le
parking et plus d'une vingtaine par la
rue alors bruno mouron se fait aider par
un autre photographe
ils vont se positionner de part et
d'autre du building en espérant avoir de
la chance
ok
ah merde à si on a notre patrie de suite
le photographe s'installe dans un café
en face de la porte principale de la
banque
l'endroit est bien placé maintenant
il faut pouvoir rester avec pile poil en
face de son bureau
là où il devrait être le photographe se
tient prêt mais un obstacle va se mettre
sur son chemin un camion vient
stationnés devant l'entrée de l'immeuble
et cache la vue
12dans 5 m
bush la butte
seule solution pour le photographe
changer de place dans le café mais là
encore il va jouer de malchance
une fois la merde pendant près de deux
heures
bruno moreau va guetter l'arrivée de
richard fuld mais ce matin là le pdg ne
se montrera pas
au téléphone il fait un point avec son
acolyte qui est en planque dans les sous
sol de l'immeuble
nous on n'a pas vu on n'a pas vu arriver
une voiture avec chauffeur
on a vu une depuis deux heures
[Musique]
le photographe décide alors d'explorer
une autre piste il y à un entre richard
fuld a acheté un appartement de 620
mètres carrés sur park avenue
le quartier huppé de new york coup plus
de 23 millions de dollars
l'adresse est connue car le luxe de
l'appartement a choqué les américains
voilà les photos avant la vente la
décoration n'était pas à son goût
le financier a donc fait pour 10
millions de travaux supplémentaires
richard fuld se cache-t-il chez lui à
quelques pas de son bureau
nous avons questionné le portier en
caméra cachée bonjour monsieur comment
allez vous monsieur bonjour je suis un
ami de richard fuld et je voudrais
savoir s'il est là non non ils n'ont pas
encore emménagé à d'accord ils
n'habitent pas encore là non il faudra
revenir plus tard
ok merci beaucoup au revoir
difficile de localiser richard fuld car
en plus de cet appartement à new york
il possède quatre maisons à travers les
états unis dont cette somptueuse villa
en floride avec vue sur l'océan piscine
et courts de tennis en tout son
patrimoine immobilier s'élève à plus de
100 millions de dollars
et c'est justement cette fortune acquise
chez lehman brothers que se voit
reprocher l'homme que tu raques goût
nous mourrons on lui reproche aussi
d'avoir continué à toucher des montants
colossaux des dizaines de millions de
dollars alors que sa société était déjà
dans le rouge
le 6 octobre dernier le congrès le somme
de s'expliquer c'est sa dernière
apparition publique depuis l'année 2000
vous avez gagné plus de 480 millions de
dollars
c'est presque un demi milliard de
dollars c'est difficile à accepter pour
beaucoup de gens votre société en
faillite
notre économie traverse une crise très
grave mais vous pouvez garder 480
millions de dollars
j'étais sont très simples sur vous est
ce que cela est juste et bien je suis
pas vraiment d'accord avec vos chiffres
c'est vrai que j'ai revendu pour 60
millions de dollars d'actions il ya deux
ans et en plus mes salaires m'ont
rapporté un peu moins de 250 millions de
dollars ce qui est toujours beaucoup je
vous la corde
oui c'est beaucoup et vous avez une
villa en floride qui vaut 14 millions de
dollars plus une autre dans l'idaho vous
et votre femme avait une collection
d'oeuvres d'art qui vaut des dizaines de
millions de dollars
quand la société marchait bien je me
suis bien payé quand elle a moins bien
marché je me suis moins bien payés
monsieur fusent il ya une faille dans ce
que vous dites car vous avez gagné
énormément d'argent quand les affaires
marchaient bien et vous avez continué en
gagner beaucoup alors que ça marchait
moins bien et maintenant les employés
petits actionnaires n'ont plus rien
après trois heures d'audience
un comité d'accueil attend richard fuld
à la sortie du congrès sur les panneaux
brandis par les manifestants on peut
lire honte cupidité
et escroc depuis personne n'a revu
richard füle mais beaucoup de monde lui
en veut particulièrement les onze mille
salariés de lehman brothers près de la
moitié des effectifs
licencié fin septembre carmine pagano et
l'un d'entre eux à 61 ans il travaillait
chez lehman brothers depuis plus de 40
ans à la fin du mois de septembre j'ai
reçu une lettre de lehman brothers qui
me disait que je ne recevrai plus aucun
salaire de leur part j'ai eu la lettre
le 28 septembre alors que mon salaire
devait arriver le 3 octobre c'est à dire
quelques jours plus tard vous couper les
vivres comme ça sans prévenir
ils ne me laissaient aucun délai pour
pouvoir me préparer à ça
carmine pagano organiser les voyages
d'affaires du groupe comme tous les
salariés de la banque il gagne bien sa
vie
8000 $ par mois aujourd'hui au chômage
ils ne touchent plus que 1200 dollars
une situation qui s'est aggravée le jour
où il a reçu une deuxième lettre de
lehman brothers ça c'est la lettre cela
dit nous avons le regret de vous
informer que suite à la faillite nous ne
sommes plus en mesure de garantir votre
couverture médicale lis votre future
retraite
donc non seulement j'ai perdu mon
salaire mais en plus j'ai perdu tous ses
avantages que je devais avoir jusqu'à la
fin de ma vie et ça ça n'a pas de prix
carmine pagano a des problèmes de dos sa
femme patricia souffre de la thyroïde
tous les deux prennent régulièrement des
médicaments leur budget santé est très
élevé mais désormais ils doivent
l'assuré sol si la situation devait
s'aggraver
il n'aurait plus le choix ils devraient
vendre leur maison
si j'en veux à dick pound oui absolument
c'était l'homme tout en haut de la
pyramide il aurait dû savoir ce qui
allait se passer
sinon ça veut dire qu'il est vraiment
stupide je l'avais en face de moi je
dirai au moins six north d'urgence hui
il ya quelques semaines
carmine pagano s'est associé à d'autres
employés pour attaquer lehman brothers
en justice il espère ainsi récupérer sa
couverture médicale et sa retraite
pour bruno mouron la traque de richard
fuld se poursuit elle l'emmène à trois
quarts d'heure de new york à greenwich
un paradis pour milliardaires avec ses
concessionnaires de voitures de luxe
c'est bijouterie et ses grandes marques
de vêtements
c'est ici que tous les grands patrons de
la finance possède une résidence
secondaire
ces maisons d'exception sont à
l'extérieur de la ville richard fuld
aurait l'une des plus somptueuses mais
sa maison demeure invisible de la route
caché par un parc de plusieurs dizaines
d'hectares
bruno mouron décide alors de prendre de
la hauteur on a de la chance pour tenter
de photographier le pdg le français va
dépenser 1500 euros pour louer un
hélicoptère avec le pilote il commence
par définir les angles de prise de vue
de la maison
repéré en photos sur internet ce qu'il
nous faut c'est un angle comme ça par
rapport à la maison on ne soit pas trop
ok on se mettra à 150 mètres au dessus
de la propriété pour avoir une vue
globale
oui et en se déplaçant doucement pour
faire de bonnes photos problème c'est
facile le photographe mise beaucoup sur
cette expédition
car il est aux états unis depuis une
semaine et richard fuld est toujours
introuvable
c'est pas que ça est aussi difficile que
ça je pense à que c'est très simple
quand on avait sans l'adresse suffisait
d'être planqué un peu pour le retrouver
mais là à mon avis c'est pire qu'une
star et milliardaire
j'ai fait ce look et on entendait bien
je mets la radio plus fort non non c'est
bon c'est ok un quart d'heure de vol
suffit pour rejoindre des propriétés de
greenwich avec golf privé étant et park
à perte de vue
le photographe repère la propriété de
richard fuld une maison de 16 pièces
avec piscine terrains de tennis et cours
intérieures de squash valeur 21 millions
de dollars
quand les employés de la maison
aperçoivent hélicoptère il cache
précipitamment les voitures dans un
garage
le photographe les mitraillent car grâce
à elle une fois au sol il espère
retrouver plus facilement la trace du
milliardaire
et les photos de ces voitures vont en
effet lui être très utile le lendemain
il les traque dans les rues de greenwich
la repérer les trois voitures qui
étaient sur un parking il ya un gros 4 4
immense 1 044 toi risque à l'aide
ja
un cherokee gris foncé mais on n'a pas
les numéros mais on a pu me regarder un
peu ce qu'ils ont de différent des
autres c'est à dire ils ont deux pays
chacun par bus de chez roquette galerie
donc peut être facilement repérables par
rapport à d'autres parce que des modèles
d'euros 4,4 ici c'est pas ce qui manque
[Musique]
quelquefois non
je regarde toujours rien
attention madame saxe 20 heures les
chars échos ce matin
après avoir sillonné la ville dans tous
les sens pendant plus de trois heures
une voiture attire son attention
ce 4 4 noir comme celui de richard fuld
compte ou nous mourrons vérifier sur la
photo qu'il a prise depuis l'hélicoptère
l'agencé m
la planque commence il n'y a plus qu'à
attendre le chauffeur madame la bonne il
a peut-être la vie réelle
la gouvernante rempli le coffre de
provisions pour le photographe c'est le
signe que richard foule n'a pas quitté
sa propriété de greenwich
c'est bon ça on à la mode commence à
avoir des ingrédients la maison après
une semaine de traque
l'enquète semble enfin progresser et le
photographe a mis au point un stratagème
qui pourrait lui permettre de toucher au
but dès ce soir 19 heures la très select
et bibliothèque publique de new york
réunit ses membres les plus prestigieux
pour récolter des fonds
une soirée de charité où tout le gratin
new york et est conviée parmi les
invités salman rushdie mais aussi
richard fields un des grands donateurs
de l'association
pour obtenir une accréditation bruno
mouron s'est fait passer pour un
photographe people venus couvrir
l'événement mais la place qui lui a été
réservé ne me convient pas
mais moi je fais rien on est là
et on sait quoi alors ils sont sympas
ils sont tous française est très bien
placé mais je parlais d'ailleurs aussi
là pourtant cette place va se révéler
stratégique car de là le photographe
voit distinctement le nom des invités
sur les cartons ils repèrent celui de
richard fuld
mais quelques instants plus tard c'est
une jeune femme qui vient retirer le
badge richard fuld et donc déjà sans
doute à l'intérieur entrée par une autre
portant richard fut lui échappe de
nouveau mais cette fois ci le dénouement
est proche retour à greenwich
soudain le photographe repère une des
voitures de richard fuld au volant c'est
la femme du milliardaire le photographe
la prend immédiatement en chasse en
prenant certains risques
bush
et si pour
quelques minutes plus tard bingo il
tient la femme de richard fuld au bout
de son objectif est tout seul mais qui
est allé faire ses courses dans un beau
dimanche après-midi et rester devant la
télé
après la piste des maisons celles des
voitures et de la soirée caritative
le photographe va avoir une intuition
pour retrouver sa cible il va le
planquer à l'occasion d'un rendez-vous
que l'homme d'affaires ne peut pas
manquer c'était le 4 novembre petit
matin ce jour là les américains
élisaient leur président bruno mouron
attendait richard fuld à l'ouverture de
son bureau de vote à greenwich
c'est là qu'elle est sortie j'ai fait il
ya deux portes l'art ça rentre ça sort
des deux côtés la porte de droite comme
de gauche
d'accord parce que là je suis bien placé
il ya du monde ou dollars j'ai pas de
lumière carola c'est pas lui c'est lui
c'est lui avec sa femme il et il rentre
dans l'aude il a atteint il est dans
l'eau dit voilà ya ce plan de caméra il
va lui passer devant c'est bon c'est bon
rolala trois photos avaient faim j'ai
grandi c'est vachement bien c'est la
blonde c'est elle c'est sa femme du vol
cette photo bruno mouron l'avant du
10000 euros en france mais il a dépensé
quasiment la même somme pour l'obtenir
trois semaines de planque
quant à richard fut lille continue de se
cacher aucune autre photo de lui n'est
paru depuis dans la presse
le fbi a ouvert trois enquêtes à son
encontre s'il a commis des irrégularités
dans la gestion de lehman brothers
il risque de passer de longues années en
prison
[Musique]
et